it hasn't been my goal to talk very much
about Bobby Kennedy Junior's candidacy
for the Democratic presidential
nomination we did talk about his
campaign launch we talked about polling
we talked about the undeniable reality
that the DNC is simply not going to hold
debates as they never do when they have
an incumbent president running for
re-election but Bobby Kennedy Jr has
really been scaling up the nuttiness he
did a Twitter spaces with Twitter owner
Elon Musk and while there were fewer
technical glitches there were there was
certainly no shortage of lies and the
things that Bobby Kennedy Jr is saying
don't make any sense they don't make any
sense and it's it's it's almost getting
concerning to a degree as I told you
before I had dinner once with Bobby
Kennedy with a small group Charming
smart able to talk logically about so
many different issues anything so many
different things knowing that he had
some odd views about vaccines at the
time
but now it's just building building he's
become the darling of Newsmax and other
right Wingers and we have to look at
some of the claims he's making because
they are so wrong and so dangerous
Business Insider summarizing the recent
Twitter spaces with Elon Musk says
Robert F Kennedy Jr Compares Elon Musk
to the patriots who died fighting in the
American Revolution what on Earth and
blames antidepressants for mass
shootings Elon Musk hosted RFK Jr in a
bizarre Twitter bizarre is right in a
bizarre Twitter spaces conversation
littered with falsehoods and conspiracy
theories Kennedy compared musk to
Patriots who died in the Revolutionary
War he also claimed prior to the
introduction of Prozac there were no
mass shootings in the United States news
to historians
um let's go through this in pieces
Kennedy said thank you for your service
to our country Elon we lost between 25
000 and 70 000 people during the
revolution who died to give us our
Constitution and those people also put
their livelihoods on the line they put
their property on the line they put
their financial status and their social
status on the line for principles I've
watched you do the same thing
folks he can't he's too smart to believe
that right he's just paying obviously
bogus lip service to Elon Musk I hope
right I hope uh Elon Musk Elon Musk is a
billionaire who owns a bunch of
companies
has a net worth around or over 200
billion although maybe it's less now
because of the decline in Tesla stock I
don't know
the patriots who fought in the American
Revolution as Bobby Kennedy says we're
mostly Farmers Artisans merchants and
laborers who quite literally risked
their lives and livelihoods for the
cause of Liberty and Independence uh
from England Elon Musk hasn't sacrificed
his life nor his fortune yes he's lost a
few billion what's a few billion to a
guy who's as rich as he is he's
benefited from government subsidies
government contracts tax breaks for his
businesses the patriots who fought in
the American Revolution pledged their
lives fortunes and quite frankly uh uh
uh put so much more at risk than Elon
Musk has even thought of risking Elon
Musk hasn't even consistently shown
support for democracy or human rights in
some situations he has done some
praising of authoritarian regime games
he's criticized some democratically
elected leaders he spread misinformation
about covet I mean listen I am not one
of these people who says Elon Musk is a
uniquely bad guy check out my appearance
on the Lex Friedman podcast where I say
I think the focus on Elon Musk is just
overblown what he has done to advance
electric vehicle technology and Battery
Technology it's fantastic it really is
SpaceX super interesting he's done a lot
of great things but he's also done
things that I think are terrible and
we're now saying he's like the American
Patriots who fought for independence in
the American Revolution it's just a
crazy thing for Bobby Kennedy to say
um he also talked about uh the SSRI
violence connection
and he said that
um as the article here points out he
laid the blame for the ink massive
increase in mass shootings not on guns
but on pharmaceutical companies for
marketing antidepressants quote prior to
the introduction of Prozac we had almost
none of these events in our country now
of course that's not true Prozac was
introduced in the United States in 1987
approved by the FDA there were endless
mass shootings before that certainly
fewer the population was smaller and
I'll tell you what the real reasons were
but if you look on Wikipedia at a list
of mass shootings you see a bunch of
mass shootings in the 20s when the
American population was much smaller
um not so many in the 30s and 40s and
50s but then they start to increase in
the 1960s we saw mass shootings in the
1970s we saw way more mass shootings in
the 19 80s before the introduction of
Prozac we saw even more so what you
actually see
is that the number of mass shootings
scaled with not only the American
population but the widespread
availability of firearms as well as
lacks gun laws when you look at a
general limit now okay let's then so
we've seen that it's not true that there
were almost no mass shootings before
Prozac just not true what about a
general link between ssris
Prozac being one type of SSRI medication
and violence more generally and this has
been asserted before the claim that
ssris cause violence it's sort of like
blaming the fire extinguisher for the
fire there's a fire in these all there's
all these fire extinguishers there all
of a sudden ssris are prescribed for a
number of different reasons including
depression anxiety or personality
disorders most people with depression
anxiety and personality disorders
aren't prone to violence but some are
and if you believe as some do that
compared to the general population
particularly certain personality
disorders might predispose someone to
violence you might be able to might
might you might be able to find a
correlation between those taking ssris
and violence but that would not be proof
that the violence is caused by the ssris
it would be the classic confounding
Factor this is like basic you know first
level College research methods and stats
sort of stuff in other words it would be
the underlying mental disorder rather
than the medication that might be the
cause of the violence but it's really
important also to mention that most
people who are quote mentally ill are
not violent it's also really important
to mention that if you also look at the
studies that look at ssris and violence
they're often significant methodological
limitations small sample size lack of
control groups failure to account for
other factors that might influence
violence like substance use or abuse
history of aggression psychosocial
stressors economic issues ETC so right
now the causal link between ssris and
violence is extraordinarily weak now
I'll give you another side to this
discussion there are studies that
suggest
ssris properly administered can reduce
Violence by improving mood and impulse
control for the those who are taking
them so not only is it unfair and
misleading to blame the ssris for
violence based on what we currently know
it actually could be the opposite
um this is getting to be pretty
dangerous stuff and I don't really know
what the end game is here for Bobby
Kennedy Jr as you all know he's not
going to be the nominee there aren't
going to be debates I would love to see
debates and I think everyone who wants
to run should run but when you see the
right Wingers increasingly excited and
titillated by Bobby Kennedy's campaign
that really tells you a lot about the
sort of campaign that is being run here
and it's not a particularly exciting
campaign to me I know that there's a
handful of people in the audience who
seem to like it but I think that it is
essentially a ruse sort of like Tulsi
gabbard was a ruse
if I'm wrong I will correct the
statement in the future